[Music]
and welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance and kissin and this
is a show for you if you're bored of
people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guest this week is
a spike columnist and the author of what
women want fun freedom and an end to
feminism
hello Wheelan welcome to Chicken Archie
hi thanks for having me oh it's a
pleasure we really look forward to
speaking with you
and as always before we get into the
show itself tell us a little bit about
how you are where you are today what's
been your journey well it was a bit of a
weird one so I never wanted to be a
journalist in fact I finished my
university degree and my masters and
thought I never ever ever want to pick
up a pen again ever I was sick of it but
the politics is what got me and so I was
sort of flirted with student politics
and then I found spikes and they were
just saying something that no one else
was saying and I went to a few meetings
held a meeting myself and then got into
it that way so it was the the politics
that really drove me to journalists and
rather than the writing as anyone who's
ever subbed one of my articles called no
just by attending should be my grandma's
still pretty poor and what was your like
kind of political evolution because a
lot of the things you talk about are
quite you it's very described azide
spoke and I think on many issues what's
been the journey that's led you to hold
these views and to be willing to express
them in public well I would previously
I've always called myself left of the
left but the problem is now I think the
left is so kind of bastardized that I
can't link myself with it anymore
because I don't recognize it as anything
left-wing inherently but so people kind
of wince when I say I'm a traditional
old-school lefty in terms of I hold
certain views on equality or money on
class
but I suppose what's made me outspoken
today is that things have gotten so mad
I really think what I say a lot at the
time is common sense and I get accused
of being general for saying most people
will think this and then give my opinion
but I do think that most people on the
whole are looking at politics today and
just completely alienated by it don't
understand how it's gotten so mad don't
understand how it's or not don't
understand but can't fathom how we're
having discussions about and the you
know political ramifications of people's
hairstyles or you know the significance
of what a politician had for dinner or
any of these ridiculous things that are
now kind of hot topics like me I think
most people are just sort of wanting to
get back to looking at the big real
issues well it's interesting we spoke to
Tom Slater who you'll know from spiked
as well a couple of weeks back and he
was talking about the fact if you look
even as something like brexit and by the
way both Francis and I remain we talk
about brexit the majority position is
the one that's demonized which is quite
incredible in and of itself so when you
talk about most people think this I
think there's so many issues on which
most people think something and that is
the position that is demonized which is
incredible place to be isn't it yeah but
it shows how completely out of step the
political establishment and to a certain
degree the media are with public opinion
so the fact that I mean I was a brexit
ear and and I see that as a pretty
standard left-wing position but the fact
is the vote was announced and then I
think it was probably bout 45 minutes
afterwards we got to celebrate in the
spiked office for about half an hour and
then we were right right we're on the
defensive and the other biggest
political mandate in British history has
been systematically demonized I like
viciously demonized for two years
straight or whatever point we're at now
and I think that isn't coming from
people people aren't stopping levers in
the street and hurling eggs at them and
saying like you've put the country to
hell it's MPs
and it's political commentators who are
really viciously against Prezi I think
that tells you about the separation it's
going on the kind of big lines in the
sand between those who are the rulers
and who make the laws and those of us
who are ruled to a sentencing
one interesting about braces is we get
quite a lot of comments and in
particular comedians who are sort of
that sort of very the left so korbinite
left and they the criticism that they
always put some ease you never get any
left-wing people on and I say actually
we do but a lot of them support brexit
and it a lot of people seem to think
that in order for you to support brixey
you need to be on the right but that's
obviously a fallacy because there's a
lot of people on the Left especially
were you consider to be the old-school
tony benn s Clift they all support Breck
CEO of large majority of Robin does as
well but yes he does he's gonna sold out
whose side of the left in relation to
breaks it I guess it's because the main
leave campaign the main phases of it
were Tory MPs or they brought don't
think you can necessarily call them
rapid right-wingers but there wasn't a
vocal left for breaks it other than
spikes we had a sore as because we could
be our campaign and he had some labor
left people who camp of campaign for
brexit but on the whole there wasn't a
coherent left-wing movement but what I
thought was this great opportunity to
break through years of mush and status
quo and not moving anywhere in politics
then you have this moment where lots of
working-class people are saying we want
to change in politics and we want to
have a greater say and we want to shake
things up and the less nowhere to be
seen so not that I revel in the fact
that that is the case but I think it
tells you a lot about where the left is
today if they were so blind as to not
see this as an opportunity to change
politics quite dramatically I mean I
remember in the two weeks after the vote
you had news about how the Tory party
was going to disintegrate about how
labour was going to disintegrate
Westminster was crumbling everyone was
falling apart and I was like yes like
this is what I vote for this is great I
mean you know I never have voted in
general elections when I was young gross
to spoil my ballot and then my mum was
said they never read the like essay that
you write you know they just see that
you haven't taken the book so anyway and
I and that was a conscious decision
because I thought none of these people
represent what I want in any way shape
or form I'm very very against picking
the best of a bad bunch but brexit was
the first thing ever in my political
career where I was like right this is
something I definitely know that I care
about I'm 107 behind this let's go and
that was I think that was a lot of
people's experience I mean the voter
turnout for breaks it was ginormous in
comparison to general elections and you
see then the general action after it
numbers completely tanked again which
tells you what you need to know about
how important this thing was and how
tragic I think it is that it's being
slammed to such a great extent I think
that is also first-past-the-post doesn't
really engage voters and in the same way
you know what I mean like it's certainly
what I lift for example there's
absolutely no point voting for anybody I
could vote for any party it would make
no difference whatsoever I could vote
for the party that's gonna win which
always wins which is in my case the
Conservatives I could work for the BNP
if they still existed it wouldn't make
any difference you know so I think the
first parts the poorest is definitely a
part of that
[Music]
but anyway I wanted to ask you your book
is called what women want fun freedom
and then to feminism what's your beef
with feminism sometimes in some shows I
get them to just read out the first bit
without the Sun I don't think that's the
bit that always freaks people out yeah
my beef with feminism is long-standing
and really though that sounds really
controversial and to feminism I think
that is the most sensible way to go for
women and for women's liberation because
I think feminism must become something
that doesn't help women at all actually
in the book argue it's something that is
the main thing that's hindering women's
freedom today I think it's become kind
of what I call a middle-class Girls Club
it's extremely elitist it doesn't have
really any interest in the political
desires of most working-class women it's
actually quite disdainful of
working-class women it's sort of very
hectoring very patronizing it dictates
to women how they should feel and how
they should act but never asks women
what they want and after I wrote the
book this really brilliant survey came
out from the Fawcett Society which has
kind of champion of feminism and they
did the survey that showed that only 7%
of women in the UK identify as feminists
it was just such a brilliant moment
because the headline they ran with the
press release was women in the UK don't
know that they're feminists who came up
with that fantastic piece of spin to
turn a terrible stat into an affirmation
of your necessity as a feminist
organisation what they were really was
saying is that women don't get it
feminism is about equality and everyone
likes the qualities they also around
another survey which was about do you
believe in equal rights for men and
women and surprise surprise pretty much
happens hope yes but so they said see
people just aren't matching this up they
don't get what feminism bout so they're
wrong we need to teach women about
feminism
and then they'll like it that's exactly
what's wrong with feminists and today I
think it treats women like they don't
get it and they need to be re-educated
you got a lot of discussion about
internalized misogyny about being sort
of brainwashed to the patriarchy when
actually most women are saying I know
what this is about it's been about since
the 70s haiti's I'm not into it actually
move on I think that's why I'm saying an
end to feminism and a beginning of
something a bit better and a bit of a
better discussion about what it is women
actually need in the 21st century and do
you think a lot of women are worried
about coming out and saying that they
don't identify as feminists or they
don't believe that they're a feminist
for instance my girlfriend who is a
she's currently doing a doctorate
someone is very very intelligent she
would she ascribe those views but she
would never feel comfortable saying that
do you think that's she's denies she's
my girlfriend
but um do you think women feel worried
about expressing those views or Judaism
is becoming more widespread I think that
it's split so I think women who have a
public profile do because you see it all
the time this celebrity has refused to
say that they are a feminist and then
you get all the kind of pieces in all
the different you know newspapers saying
how dare they they're a traitor and they
really have a responsibility to do all
that so it's a bit of a social marker it
gives you kind of cultural capital it
says you're in the right group you used
to be trusted or the right person but I
think most other women who don't have to
worry about where their next media gigs
gonna come from and have more
interesting jobs than you know selling
themselves for newspapers don't worry
about it because it's kind of like I
said a common sense position you know we
could go outside now to the high street
and stop a woman on the street and I bet
my life savings little as they are they
would not say feminists if you ask them
what they're identified with it's
politically they might say conservative
labor left-right but they just wouldn't
say feminist because it's not it's not
coherent movement people don't have
meetings in town
about feminism there's no party there's
the women's equality party but it's
failed to get anyone elected not because
it doesn't have a coherent clever
campaign but because no one's interested
this isn't something that women want to
organize around it doesn't mean that
there aren't still things that hold
women back today but for the need for
any kind of gender specific movement I
think has passed or even I think wasn't
there wasn't ever desire for it in the
first place do you think we need a new
word because the way I think about it is
like if we talk about the the definition
of feminism that has always thrown out
in order to convince people that they
are feminists ISM do you like you said
do you believe in equality between men
and women the women should have equal
opportunities with men I'm a FEMINIST by
that definition not everybody is I
imagine ninety-nine percent of people
are but increasingly that is not what
feminism seems to be about so is it a
matter of definitions that we need to
kind of distinguish between that and
whatever this fourth wave of a third
wave feminism must become well as a
journalist it's bad to say this but I
think we are getting hung up on words or
certainly people do get hung up on words
in relation to discussion about families
I mean here lots of people saying we
just need a new kind of rebrand and
that's partly what full set the that's
partly what the Fawcett Society was
saying we just need to change it up we
need to reconvince people it's not just
the kind of term it's not just that
people don't get that it's about
equality it's exactly as you said it's
become something that is not about
equality in fact it never really was so
the thing that annoys me as well as you
get discussion about feminism this year
is the 100th anniversary of some women
some rich property-owning women getting
the vote during the suffragette movement
and people talk about feminism and the
suffragettes the feminism was a word
that was used then the suffragettes were
not feminists that's a total ignorant
reading of history as factually
incorrect feminism as a kind of movement
only came about really in the late 70s
and the 80s so and it was very much then
a movement that was based around
theory it was largely middle-class
although it had some campaigns that were
related to equality in the law around
contraception but it was never a really
sort of ground-up movement it was net
there was never a kind of coherent
massive women's movement there were
reactions to things and there were
protests which came in the context of
the sexual revolution in changes in
relation to the civil rights movement
but there has never been you know people
talk about feminism like it's this thing
in history that's existed and and as has
a long kind of standing and a movement
that you can kind of point to actually
know it's completely scattered it's
completely fragmented so I don't think
it was good from the start really and
that doesn't mean I don't think by the
way that paying men and women equally is
bad all the things that did come out of
women's movements in that time and were
bad I think that what we need now is a
very clear-headed look at what it is
that women still need so we still need
better access to childcare still needs
abortion rights we still need better
access to society's resources in some
cases so we still have a situation in
which rightly or wrongly women are still
seen as as I call it the chief knows
wipers the ones who are going to
remember the doctor's appointment the
ones who are gonna you know in my house
know that you've got to unroll the socks
where you put them in the washing
machine which you can laugh about and
I'm not saying that that's you know I'm
like oh we're at pressed no but but it's
it's it's women's position society still
as the caregivers and that's reinforced
by in some ways the way in which work
workers operate you know childcare means
that because women are seen as the main
caregivers they're the ones that have to
take the time off work which means then
when they go back into work you have the
motherhood gap in contrast to the gender
pay gap which we might talk about a bit
later you know very small things like
this is one of my
for examples there's a law which says
that you it's an EU law actually breaks
it which says that you can't advertise
formula milk as the same or equal to
breastfeeding that might sound like a
very small point but actually what that
is saying is that women should be
breastfeeding all the time when they are
when the baby is first born and there
are sort of health campaigns suggest
that breast is best not that kind of
thing well that's really saying is you
can't have a life because anyone who's
breastfed knows that it's 24 hour on the
hour job that's reinforcing women as the
primary caregivers and that has knock on
effects so that's what I mean and and
you know how do you fix that can you
pass a law saying men have to look after
the kids no that would be stupid who
would want to do that
do you have awareness raising campaigns
no it's about thinking more clearly
about what are the practical things that
could help that situation removing that
EU law might be one getting better
access to child care might be another
but you never have that you have people
are piling on the television about how
you know it's so sexist that they have
to wear this dress code or whatever to
work or how it's so sexist that they're
told off for breastfeeding in public or
all this kind of crap really
which is just attention-seeking in my
point of view not a kind of real serious
look at what it is that women needs I've
read a very interesting article that you
wrote in some way we're talking about
International Women's Day and actually
how annoying you found it and I did
actually find it very very funny could
you just explain to us why you find that
entire movement because I think the
words you use were patronizing well why
is it that you find these kind of
initiatives patronizing and also not
particularly helpful it's because it
positions women as weak and oppressed so
the kind of in reality we can say that
on the whole in the UK or in the West
women are not oppressed we have equality
under the law it's illegal to treat us
differently you can bring someone to
call if they do while there might be
sort of nuances in the way
which men and women are treated
differently in certain social situations
on the whole we have it pretty good and
that is because of the fights of women
in the past so I have a good life
because women of my mother's generation
my grandmother's generation stood up to
injustice so we got it good but just as
we get to a position where we are you
know enjoying relative freedom and it's
all going pretty rosy
we've now got this narrative that things
are terrible so you're telling young
women that even though in their
day-to-day lives they're seeing that
they're not being stopped by their
gender there's nothing this because
there are women is telling them that to
hold themselves back or anything and
you've got the political narrative
saying no no you are oppressed you are a
victim and you need International
Women's Day because that will be the day
where we will you know raise your plight
to the world and I don't think there's
anything more patronizing than telling
someone who thinks everything's fine
that they actually don't get it that no
they really are oppressed and pushing
that victim narrative on them it's
essentially like saying that we can't
get along on our own I also think
international men's day is the load of
bollocks as well that's that's the kind
of the terrible oh the tone of that kind
of identity politics right the idea that
you need an International Day for each
gender it's like what I mean who even
buys into that and you look at who does
buy into that it's you know the UN's
women's department who put out a
campaign with Wonder Woman the other
year I mean talk about insulting or the
Fawcett Society or you know every
journalist including me understand who
wants to get a column out of it and
that's about it I mean isn't it also you
can argue that it's you know
although women in this country are
perceived to be equal whatever the case
may be but in lots of other countries I
mean there's still a lot of inequality
and women's rights are not where they
should be
surely yeah
definitely and doesn't mean that you
don't show solidarity with those
campaigns but I don't think that Western
feminism is something for women who are
struggling for freedom in different
parts of the world to look up to because
if you take for example not too far away
where I'm from in islands just across
the pond there's been a long-standing
women's movement for abortion rights
which actually interestingly hasn't been
that colored by feminism so there are
feminist groups who have been
campaigning for abortion rights but on
the whole it's been a discussion about
bodily autonomy it's been a discussion
about what Ireland wants the
Constitution to mean it's been really
you know the conversation has been of
such good quality it's been so political
it's been so serious and that's been
hugely successful and that was fighting
against some serious injustice I mean
women were dying because they weren't
being allowed the basic medical care if
they couldn't fly to England to get
treatment so none of the kind of victim
narrative that I'm talking about in
relation to the kind of feminism we see
in the UK although it does happen in
Ireland a bit more we tend to be a bit
more screwed on in Ireland it didn't
really touch it and that's what I mean
by saying you can say that women being
forced to cover their heads in Iran is
wrong women being you know in some
countries used as sex slaves and all
that kind of stuff is wrong that doesn't
mean that you need to buy into this very
unproductive very sort of self-absorbed
feminism that we've got in the West I
mean it's a particular brand in the US
and the UK of feminism that just kind of
asks women to start their own backsides
and make something political out of that
it's like all about how you feel it's
all about how you value yourself as a
woman it's all about you know how you
should be represented it's it's so so so
boring and you've actually argued that
this excessive introspection leads to
mental health problems like particularly
young girls I read an article that you
were spiked where you were talking about
it can you elaborate on that a little
bit so I saw some shocking stats you
shouldn't always trust the stats that
you read cuz often they've got kind of
political
- behind them but it is the case that
we've got quite a large uptick in
numbers of young girls self-harming now
I'm sure that what's classified as self
harming isn't all people very seriously
hurting themselves and putting their
lives in danger and I don't think that
all means that all these women have
serious mental health problems
teenage girls tend to flirt with that
kind of thing a little bit rightly or
wrongly doesn't necessarily mean they
have a long-lasting problem however
that's a bit weird young women in not
young men but young women are deciding
to hurt themselves and the reasons that
they're giving is that they don't feel
good enough they don't feel valued
enough they feel you know under pressure
from the image that women are seen in
society when I was young we still had
models we still had you know we didn't
quite have the internet we were just on
the cusp of it but we had magazines I
knew of beauty standards there was a
desire to be thin when you're at school
all of that stuff still existed but we
weren't troubling ourselves with it too
much and yes there was the odd person
that would let it get to them but today
you have in contrast this huge push to
tell young girls that they might have a
problem so you've got initiatives of I
used to work in a school you've got
initiatives of he for she which is the
UN kind of campaign going in and talking
to girls about their body image and
about how they should be respectful of
themselves and how they should value
themselves and it's really just giving
teenagers problems I mean one way to
make a teenager have a complex is to
tell them that they could possibly have
a complex it's it's like feeding them
the problem so if you're saying to young
girls Society is stacked against you
Society is telling you you've got to be
thin you've got to be beautiful you've
got to have 70 plus likes on your
Instagram post or or you might self-harm
which is everything that I see in the
news all the time is these stories and
they get kind of they get these poor
girls in front of a camera when I'm talk
about how they don't haven't felt very
good about their body image is so
exploitive and you're just giving them a
problem whereas there I've gone into so
much trouble in the past for saying the
best way to deal with
self-absorbed teenager who doesn't have
a serious problem
is to say get over yourself and this is
not an interesting thing to be worried
about and yet we're just sort of
indulging this rubbish and this kind of
teenage fantasy and it's having some
dark consequences lo and behold talk
about teenagers have a problem you
suddenly have lots of teenagers having a
problem no I mean it's a very
interesting point I mean we there was
the whole me - movement which happened
obviously last year and I read some
really fascinating articles on your
opinion of me - where do you stand on it
do you think it was a by and large a
positive thing or do you think it was
negative or like like everything there
were positives and negatives to it mmm I
think it from the start wasn't a good
thing not of the opinion that it was a
good intention thing that went bad I
think from the off it had problems and
it was pretty much completely based on
the problematic idea that you would use
social media and you would use these
public platforms to kind of essentially
do show trial so yes Harvey Weinstein I
think we can all agree it's not a
pleasant man and that's I would I'm not
a lawyer I don't know the cases but you
know if we were having a bet in a pub
I'd say that he did do those things to
those women I don't think it's hard to
believe that that was the case however
it began with this accusation of Harvey
Weinstein which only came out because
the New York Times did an expose let's
remember not because a group of women
suddenly decided they wanted to you know
do something about this and then and
then immediately became something that
wasn't just about Harvey Weinstein
wasn't just about one case it became me
- and what that was when that hashtag
hit the internet was saying tell us
about your experiences of abuses or not
even tell us about the details of your
experiences of abuse just say me - and
then immediately after that you had you
know serious surveys and think pieces
and you know political analysis using
this you know very and substantial way
of measure
you know people tweeting the words me
too to say that there was this onslaught
of abuse that there was this kind of
tidal wave of sexual harassment we had
this serious problem and you know for
anyone who's very serious about you know
thinking sexual harassment is something
terrible and wrong that was a it's a
very bad thing to happen because you
have the blurring of lines you have
people talking about oh me too
my boss once asked me out on a date
that's not sexual harassment that's you
know inappropriate behavior perhaps if
you don't fancy him but it's but it's
not sexual harassment you have people to
isn't that sort of the conversation here
often it becomes difficult because isn't
there a power issue there take your
example right let's say your boss asked
you out and you say no potentially there
is there are consequences to that
depending on how that relationship works
where your refusal to go on a date with
him is then connected to your
opportunities for promotion your salary
you pay Rises whatever right so isn't it
about power of this whole conversation
and that's why it can be an issue when
you're dating your boss asked you out on
a date no I think it that is a power
issue and that doesn't happen very often
it isn't the case that bosses are asking
out there pretty young secretaries left
right and center and then you know given
them the boot when they don't go out
with them we have pretty strict laws in
place that regulate the workplace I
think most workplaces actually have
clauses that say you can't have
relationships within the you know within
the office so I think is kind of a bit
dystopian as you spend most of your
working life in an office with people
it's kind of terrible to tell them that
you can't you know get off with the
Christmas party with them and let it all
out that's one of the things that's
really annoyed me about the me2 movement
is that it's it's just a given now that
oh yes there are abuses of power in
workplaces and all yes bosses are doing
this and it's terrible for women it's a
very dangerous situation it's not
happening it might have happened and it
did happen actually in the kind of
sixties and seventies and you've had
these older feminists and Robinson
Damon Lesley come out and say when I was
a young report
when I was a young worker people were
grabbing my backside people putting
their hands up my skirt people were you
know pinning me in corners that doesn't
happen now it did happen then and then
we had you know equality objectives come
in to workplaces we had legal you know
parameters per in relation to how people
can relate in the workplace we have all
these things in place the idea that we
now need more that we now need you know
to have affirmative consent in the
workplace or that you need to have
investigations into the power relations
it's just completely unfounded it isn't
happening the meaty movement is not a
movement it was a moment and it's got no
substantial evidence to it if you know I
think I'm feel it's not a scientific
analysis but I feel pretty confident in
saying we do not have an epidemic of
sexual harassment in the workplace in
the West because I think if we did women
would be doing something about it like
we did something about it 30 40 50 years
ago you think this is the thing that
really gets to me
do we think women are just sort of
staying quiet and being mouses and not
doing anything when bad things happen to
them in the workplace and all it took
was a hashtag from this celebrity to
suddenly break us free I mean I can't be
the only one who thinks that's pretty
insulting I do know a lot of people
whose argument to that would be well
that's exactly what's happened women
were keeping quiet about these things
because they felt like they had no power
to express themselves to share and this
hashtag in the movement that came with
it was the opportunity that allowed them
to go actually yeah me too
I've had that experience I didn't talk
about it because I was scared I was
worried I didn't know what to do I felt
like I might get fired whatever and I
know people who would say well this was
an opportunity this to social media for
women to see that actually for the first
time they have a chance to speak out and
be heard I don't buy it I just don't buy
it because I think if you look at the
history of women's movements and you
know one of the great examples I was
used as the Ford Dagenham strikers that
wasn't about sexual harassment but it
was about abuse of power in the
workplace
that internet wasn't invented then they
didn't have celebrities backing their
calls and fact they were demonized for
wanting to be paid and valued for their
work in the right way
those were working-class women they
didn't have a great education they
didn't have a great wealth they didn't
have any of the stuff that these
celebrities Economist's have at their
disposal who are you know pushing the
meaty argument and yet they still stood
up and fought for their rights and won
their rights to you know not not
immediately but eventually they did and
why do we think that women today don't
have that kind of power because it's not
true they do why do we think that women
you know will stand for bad behavior or
stand for injustice that we haven't ever
in the last kind of 60 years it's been
history shown us movement upon movement
moment upon moment of women standing up
and fighting for themselves that's why I
am totally comfortable today sitting
here saying that and talking about it
because it's not controversial so it
just really rubs me the wrong way and I
think it's actually a disservice to
women to say that we were waiting for
the permission of a very wealthy woman
in Hollywood
to allow us to speak I think you know as
as someone who really believes in
women's liberation that rubs me the
wrong way as someone also actually who's
a left-winger that rubs me the wrong way
in all ways I think Wow that I don't
think we realized what a big statement
you're making when you say that's the
case that women's silence was broken by
Alyssa Milano
one of the other mysteries brought to me
by a lot of women as to why me to is
necessary is conviction rates of sexual
assault and crimes like rape and what
women have to go through in order to
report them and then it gets taken to
trial and that a lot of women are simply
either intimidated by the process or you
just cannot bear to go through and then
be cross-examined about what is a
horrendous experience this is a
difficult one and we need to have more
discussion about our rape laws and how
situations of rape and sexual violence
are dealt with
but I think the conversation about it
has gone too far the other way now and
that sounds terribly unsympathetic but
what I mean is that we've got movements
like believe the victim which was
centered around a case in Ireland of two
rugby players who were eventually
acquitted of charges of rape and people
came out and said that they believed the
victim that they thought that this
ruling was wrong there's been calls
linked to the me2 movement but actually
it came before hand of liberalizing the
way in which we treat rape victims now
it's it's pretty much universal that
people are called rape victims instead
of complainants before our cases you
know finally decided yes so we have a
complete destruction of the presumption
of innocence and that is no good for
women I mean that's no good for either
party but that is no good for women
because that's not treating your case
seriously if you are coming to the
police and you have been raped or
sexually abused you've got a very
serious charge against someone and if
you want justice you have to take that
very seriously and that means going
through quite a difficult process and
that's not fair and that's not nice and
I have never been raped but I can't
imagine that it's in any way pleasant to
have to relive that experience in front
of strangers but if you are trying to
put someone in jail for something wrong
that they have done you have to be able
to you know be strong enough to do that
because it's a very serious thing to do
the other problem is that this is not
rape but sexual abuse sexual harassment
has sexual violence our terms which have
become so willy so you have for example
the the new law in Nottingham Shearer
which I came out I think about two years
ago which turns misogyny into a hate
crime and that meant that technically
under the law
men who Wolff whistled at or made
comments that women in the street could
be penalized under sexual harassment now
if we're talking about how to treat
sexual violence sexual harassment and
rape and police resources and how
seriously we take women I think that's
pretty damning to say that you expect
police officers to watch women as they
walk down the street in case someone
says hey sexy legs
you know and and to put that on a to put
that on a spectrum and to put that in
the same grouping as having to deal with
someone who's been brutally raped is fun
but only take that point but I think
what Francis is getting that is if
you're a woman and you have the
perception whether they attack you or
not that your rape accusation is not
going to be dealt with seriously it's
not going to be treated seriously you're
unlikely to succeed you're going to go
through a tremendous amount of trauma
relive your horrible experience then
something like me too is an opportunity
to do anonymous link perhaps or to join
your voice with others to get attention
for the fact that something happened
that you're not going to get justice for
through the criminal justice system so
and I think that that's kind of what
Francis is getting at so that's maybe an
issue where something like me to our
time's up or do come in and play a
useful role because it gives women who
feel like otherwise they don't have a
chance at justice well I think that's
where it plays the most damaging role
because that's where you have people
accusing rape and calling people rapists
without a fair trial and as we know what
happens on the social media right you're
only sticks and you can have people
making false accusations the CPS in this
country is currently reviewing of great
many rape cases because there have been
so many young men wrongly convicted
there was guy
Liam recently who was released and hang
off mail because they hadn't looked at
his text messages but you know the CPS
is it's kind of mired in these mistakes
and that's not saying that women lie
actually it's a tiny tiny tiny minority
of women who lie it's you know
inconsequential but the fact is if you
don't have a system which fairly treats
both complainants and the accused which
treats justice seriously and is sort of
beyond politics to a certain extent not
that the criminal justice systems beyond
politics but the kind of political realm
of Twitter is not something that can be
trusted to deal with something like a
rape accusation seriously I mean I don't
think any
of us would believe a tweet as facts
would we so the problem is I think today
is that and that that does happen you
have had for example Aziz Ansari the
young American actor who had this
experience sexual experience with a
woman he sounded like a bit of an even
with too many women to care or he hasn't
been with a man many women at all
because what he the way he treated her
wasn't very nice wasn't very gentlemanly
but it was consensual she was very very
up for it because he was a star and she
was pushing it and in the morning she
decided I didn't like what happened she
texted him he was actually profusely
apologetic whatever she then uses this
as a meet example of me too and it takes
is gets taken into this conversation
about sexual harassment he gets
completely lambasted on social media
he's he you know I think he pretty much
lost most of his work he's now tried to
come back to work and has been rejected
and people have mounted campaigns to
stop him from ever working again he
didn't do anything he was he was bad in
bed and he needs a lesson on how to you
know treat women politely that is that
is that's what happens when you leave
but you know we can laugh about that and
we should but I don't think it seasons
always laugh and and you know it does a
disservice to what we see as justice you
know it if you want if you have been
raped as a woman this is the other point
and that I think matters most to me more
than anything else and that's something
that someone did to you that was
completely out of your control actually
it doesn't have very much to do with sex
at all it's about power and it's about
violence and it's the removal of your
agency
I think what the me to movement in it's
almost and I'm picking my words really
carefully here glorification of being a
victim in its celebration of victimhood
in the kind of like me to which you can
see is a good thing in terms of women
should be able to speak out about this
for sure I'm not up for silencing anyone
but the kind of badge wearing of it that
doesn't sit right with me because if
you're telling women that we should
interpret this act that someone did to
us that was against our will and we
didn't want to be part of our identity
you've got to kind of slap that on like
a scarlet letter on your back and wear
that for the rest of your life I don't
think that's how we should be dealing
with red actually I think that we should
as much as we can encourage victims of
wait rape men or women to go beyond and
get over that experience and live their
lives as if it never happened because
you know it's screwed the guy or whoever
did that to you and don't let him beat
control you outside of that you know ten
minutes hour whatever it was that
timeframe that's the thing that I think
gets me most about the me to movement is
the celebration of victimhood which I
don't see as healthy do you think it's
also quite hypocritical as well in that
when we see the Asia Argento case and
then when she was accused of this by it
was a minor I know he was seventeen but
in terms of the United States and the
law he was he's seen as a minor and I
think was Rose McGowan tweeted something
about we don't know the full facts be
gentle I think well her words and I'm
and I was sorry I agreed with certain
but with parts of the meat and I'm but
when I read that was like well no you
can't really say that you can't that's
hypocritical you can't go after one
person with teeth bed and all of a
sudden just because somebody's your
friend or connected with you always a
certain gender gender agenda we have to
in inverted commas be gentle yeah I
think that was she's deleted that tweet
which you know because she's been so
hounded by it by people rightly I think
the Asia Argento story was a real moment
in which you could have been like haha
hypocrites
you know told you so this whole thing is
a load of crap and and revel in it
actually I think that the Asia Argento
story is sad and it reinforces my point
of what how wrong the meeting movement
is because we don't know that she did
that to this guy it's what he alleges
it's a kind of closed agreement for a
financial strange kind of payoffs they
have in America so your other than
opening a criminal case you're never
going to get to the bottom of whether or
not her and Anthony Bourdain her her
boyfriend at the time paid this guy up
the kindest of the heart or whether they
were shutting her up because she had sex
with him unfortunately for her there
have now been some leaked text messages
that shows that she was boasting about
having sex in so you know probably did
have sex with him but the point is you
don't have the full facts and suddenly
she is now the accuser the accused and
she is the enemy and she's evil and
she's terrible she was an abuser you
know who knows I would sort of looking
at that objectively thing why wouldn't
he want to have sex with a good-looking
celebrity you know this doesn't
necessarily have to be abuse there's a
whole range of different outcomes for
this and yet we've boiled it down to the
accused and the accuser and the writer
and the wrong and the right and that's
why meaty was so unjust
not just because Rose McGowan is
hypocritical and her treatment of those
who are accused
I mean she's not alone in that Lena
Dunham was rightly trounced for you know
on the one hand saying me too was this
fantastic thing and we should kind of
blankly and blindly believe the victim
and then on the other hand when the
writer of girls was accused of rape she
was like I'll but I know this guy and
he's kind of nice but but you know
wouldn't wouldn't you if your brother or
your best friend you'd say well we I
think you know I'm sticking by this
person until I see the facts Oh Frances
know it gets accused of anything I'm
walking right
but that that's that's what we've lost
the presumption of innocence and even
though Asia Argento is you know I don't
know the woman but I think that she's
politically suspect she what she's done
in relation to the meteor movement and
all this kind of a pioneer and it's
pretty disgusting now that you've seen
that she is sort of a kind of hypocrite
in relation to this case none of that
really matters what matters is the
destruction of the presumption of
innocence and this I think Asia Argento
case is fueling that and I see it still
is kind of problematic so I'm not
reveling in her downfall arch I think
it's part of the problem well I do think
the hypocrisy is important I mean you
see it right now with the conversation
and the Labour Party about anti-semitism
and I see all the time people who are
under what I call the loonie left right
there there are straight white people
very often explaining to Jews
what anti-semitism is about and stuff
like that whereas if it happened to any
other minority would they would be
instantly shutting those people down go
your whites planning your mansplaining
your this planning or that's planning
but for some reason when it comes to
certain people it's okay
for other people to explain to them what
it is to be discriminated against or
whatever and I do think hypocrisy is a
big part of all these issues is this
idea that you treat different groups
differently because they're different
groups instead of having the same
standard of equality for everybody and I
did and I kind of do feel that that
hypocrisy reveals a lot of the flaws in
this way of thinking where it's all
about oppression and power
intersectionality instead of just going
how about we treat everybody equally
yeah one of the things that I wrote in
the book which is such a great example
of hypocrisy is and you might have to
bleep this out so it's just such a
beautiful counter posing this is is on
the one hand you've got the free the
nipple campaign and you've got largely
middle-class feminists talking about the
fact that women are oppressed because
they can't feed their child in public
because society is so prudish about
women's naked breasts
and you've got in support of that on
Instagram which is a largely kind of
affluent middle-class social media
platform lots of rich kids on there and
you've got these sort of lovely skinny
little young things putting up topless
pictures saying free the nipple it's all
very artsy it's all very tasteful it's
all very trendy great those kind of
boobs fine then you've got page three
and you've got grid girls that they
don't get their knockers out there just
wear nice dresses you've got the Sun
you've got glamour models and that's bad
you know that's oppression that's
terrible that kind of nakedness in women
is wrong and that's influenced by men no
no they're kind of you know the the
picture that you put up an Instagram
which is really sexy and topless is vine
because it's free the nipple but the one
that you were a succes with the you know
34d chest puts up in and gets through
injured quit for it is wrong and that's
such a kind of hypocritical argument
because what are you talking about
you're talking about women's freedom to
be naked are you talking about
censorship you talk about prudish
society or are you talking about good
boobs bad boobs and though that sounds
like a fun a very specific almost silly
example it really gets to the heart of I
think the problem with feminism because
if it's working-class Essex girls in the
Sun it's bad and if it's working-class
grid girls or if it's the darks girls or
if it's any of these kind of women who
are using their bodies to work rightly
or wrongly whatever your opinion on that
then that's bad but if it's these more
middle-class women who are sort of
making an artistic statement or trying
to you know make a political statement
about breastfeeding or whatever even
though that I think is [ __ ] is is
good and that's a class distinction you
know that's a it's a kind of anti
working-class position because as
Harriet Harman said I remember reading
this fantastic article where she said I
think the Kardashians are so empowering
and they're so wonderful you know the
Kardashians who
the kind of Queens of selling the naked
bodies for fame they're brilliant and
then I think it was Piers Morgan said to
her but you know what about page three
girls who were doing the exact same but
for far less money she said no no no
that's terrible because they're
controlled by men and you think well so
that's like you know the hypocrisy there
is is tantalizingly from you know just
amazing is that such a clear way of
saying this is not a movement feminism
that cares about women's freedom I just
say I feel this is a very serious issue
that requires further yeah when you were
talking about the free the nipple
movement I just thought yeah after 10
years in relationship my girlfriend is
not in favor of that anymore certainly
someone did a very very good comedian a
comment but it was did a very funny
tweet about it about the whole darks
girls issue and they said that finally
left-wing third wave feminists will be
able to enjoy darts and peace this video
wasn't me the person that
[Music]
we touched on the gender pay gap what
would you like to tell us about the
gender page gap so I call it a myth and
that upsets people but it is a myth we
have the law which says that you cannot
pay men and women the different amounts
of money for the same work that's been a
law for very long time is one that's on
the whole respected but then the gender
pay gap is the claim that you know for
every pound that men and women earn you
know 2p or something terrible there it's
always the stats are completely
unreliable and you know in the book I
gave about four different or four or
five different stats in the space of
like a year that were given by different
organizations for women won't earn the
same amount until 2050 or 2110 or you
know just think get your act together
and can you all just agree on one myth
and then peddle that rather than doing
the different ones and when you look
break down any of those stats however
you see that what gets conflated is
different work skills and different
hours and different job levels so it's
never the case ever that Joe and Jane
who clock in at 9:00 and clock out at
5:00 on the same desk get paid
differently because as I said that's
illegal it will be the case that you
know Joe who is working 72 hours full
time gets paid different to Jane who is
working part-time freelance for a
similar role so there are so many things
to consider and I think it's just really
disingenuous to talk about something
like that without being serious about
the numbers so you had all these kind of
very very high paid like telephone but
number kind of salary paid women in the
BBC talking about the gender pay gap and
how terrible it was and how you know
oppressed they were and about if you
said to one of them oh okay so you did
what did we did we did a three hour
radio show and you got paid you know
whatever hundreds of thousands for that
and while you were doing that in the
studio there was this Nigerian guy who
was cleaning your desk
and your office for three hours and he
got 25 quid or fifty quid or wherever it
was what about that pay gap you know
what are you actually talking about
you're actually talking about people
being paid fairly are you actually
talking about raising wages are you
actually talking about giving people
what they need to live no this is a kind
of very very shallow very self-serving
attempt for some women to get pay rises
and it tends to be richer women I think
it's been really used and abused the one
thing where there is pay inequality is
what I call the motherhood pay gap
that's not bosses being sexist against
mothers that's not you know even the
fact that capitalism as a structure
means that's one part of the family if
there are two parts has to stay at home
and regenerate that you know I don't
want to get into all of this with you
but you know that kind of argument this
is about the fact that because of poor
access to childcare women who have
children tend to on the whole because
it's too expensive to hire up
babysitters and all that kind of thing
take time off work to raise their kids
that means they're out of the working
world and when they come back because
they have had to take time out that
doesn't mean that by the way people
don't we don't force people to get
pregnant that is also a free choice but
when they come back they have less
opportunity they've they you know they
don't get paid as much on the whole and
I guess you would argue that if a man
were to do that same thing you probably
would get exactly the same fatherhood
gap if he was to take time because it's
about access to childcare and and you
know as I say that's a very simple thing
that you could fix very quickly I argue
firm and and it's piked argues for free
access to 24-hour good quality childcare
on-demand very simple something like the
NHS that the state could provide why not
but instead you've got this kind of
[ __ ] about women being oppressed in
the gender pay gap and it's just another
case in which you're just having the
completely wrong conversation you're
having this sort of fantasy conversation
about sexism and work when you could be
doing this really concrete thing which
is addressing one of the key things that
stops women from going back to work or
having
a good score sort of quality of time at
work but no let's carry on paddling the
myth about the gender pay gap and you
know some great facts out there are that
women in their 20s and 30s are out
earning men you could say that's a good
thing you could say that's a bad thing
what's happening so it means that women
in their twenties and thirties aren't
being hindered by their sex or by the
you know by their gender we've got more
women going into all different types of
workplaces which we've been this big
push for women in STEM women are
flooding into stem I don't think
necessarily off the back of kind of
government-funded pushes but just
because they're interested in it it's
you know so the world is open as a woman
no there's no area in which you will
kind of be stopped because you are a
woman the one highest in the stats of
gender pay gap the one highest industry
which I think is a terrible shame was
construction you know what we're going
to say that that there's no women in
construction when women get badly paid
in construction wonder why that is I
used to work with my dad who was a
builder it's back-breaking work most
women can't do it or don't want to do it
you know because you you need to be a
big burly guy like my dad was so it's
just ridiculous I mean it's utterly
ridiculous that is an interesting part
of this whole fight for equality that it
always seems to be a fight for equality
in all the best bits isn't it so there's
very little fighting to there for
quality in the bin men endure the bitter
person industry you know women are not
really clamoring to be you know
emancipated and that right so it's all
about TV jobs radio jobs in banking
whatever and it destroys I mean it this
kind of discussion and this gendering of
this debate destroys workplace
solidarity so for most workers on who
like you say aren't in the media aren't
in these kind of high-flying highly paid
jobs you're you're working experience
you want to have solidarity or if you
like me believe in workers power you
want to have solidarity between men and
women so you don't want to have a
meeting about the
that everyone's getting a pay cut and
you know you're going to mobilize skill
and strike and then some of the women
say oh well actually we want to have our
own thing because this is going to
affect us differently when it isn't when
you should be banding together that's I
think something damaging for anyone who
actually cares in about workers rights
and you've got this in other areas I
mean quotas and and sort of to give
women leg ups to separate women out from
men in workplaces to say they are
different they need to have a different
say in the boardroom or they need to
have a different position
utterly destroys the idea of workplace
solidarity I mean it is a fact that if
you are a you know let's take to Tesco
workers in Tottenham once a man and ones
women they're pretty much going to have
the same in common in relation to their
working life their experience at work
they're probably even their political
desires at work the idea that that woman
would have any kind of solidarity with
carry grace at the BBC or you know is is
trashed of course it's not and why are
you saying that that should be the case
okay what is it like being you having
these opinion um when I'm on Twitter or
any kind of place like that it's
sometimes rough because people are very
intolerant to it I think the tone of the
debate certainly around feminism or any
of these kind of sacred cows today is so
vicious so if you if you voice opinion
that's critical of it people say I've
been called a rape apologist I've been
called a misogynist all of that kind of
stuff which you know hurts because of
something I care very deeply about
women's liberation and that's that's you
know I would never want to be associated
with anything like that but outside of
that you know where I'm on my friends
when I go out when I'm you know I'm just
living and outside of the online world
it's fine because like I said most
people I think are a bit sick of the
tone of the debate and you know wherever
I'm talking to and the women that I do
at serve glasses whoever this herbal
Center in Holloway or wherever it's my
mates or anyone we can have sensible
discussions about this and we can have
sensible degree municipal on a panel
with you know whoever and any kind of
any sort of wide core the professional
feminists who have a stake in their
career in being this kind of belligerent
and then then it gets a bit heated but
I'm fine with that because I really
really believe in this and I really want
to see a world in which women are
completely free and that's this is the
main reason why I've spent so bloody
long arguing about this and some days I
do get really sick of it but it's
because I think there's so much at stake
we've still got so much to gain
especially in relation to you know
boredom rights these kind of big issues
we should stop wasting time on this crap
of like you know whether or not the air
conditioning in a building and it's
levels set to colder for men and you
know is sexist or which is one thing I
want the basis when I was younger
well I'm glad to report says we're
watching this issue is always incredibly
[ __ ] hot we have anti-sexist the
trigonometry severe in temperature just
cut cut the crap and talk about what it
is you actually won and and how about
listen to some women who have something
to say and stop kind of taking your cue
of the situation of women from these
very middle-class very politically
suspect feminists I think
[Music]
one thing that I really admire you for
is the way you speak up because there is
a culture of fear now and there just
simply is and where people who don't
believe in the status quo or certain
movements they do feel that they will be
publicly shamed I've seen women on line
make reasonable point against me too and
then they get just get shut down and you
know they get these epithets against
them I mean what do you think ultimately
is a solution to this do you think it's
more people coming out is it what can we
do because at the moment it feels like
there's a sort of mob mentality
especially online I think it's just more
debate and that sounds like a very
wishy-washy way to deal with some very
real things that are happening like
people being hounded off social media or
people being having insults hurled at
them or whatever it is being shy of
discussions but it's just to keep
reiterating the fact that you know even
if you're a whatever extreme of the end
of discussion you're on to have free
speech that's why I'm a kind of free
speech absolutist as what we call it as
spiked
is saying that there is no opinion that
shouldn't be heard and so even if you
you know sometimes for my sins I decided
to delve into some debates with some
men's rights activists you know just for
the hell of it but just because I think
I want to know what you guys are up to I
want to know what's coming from this
strange corner of the internet so that
you know if anyone ever asked about it I
know what's going on in the same way
that I want to know what you know
whatever family has written in The
Guardian at all so whatever kind of you
know reactionary has written and you
know the male or the conservative women
or anything like that it's it's you know
you have to have if you want to have any
kind of healthy political debate you
have to allow everyone to have their say
on it but then you also have to pass
judgment I think so the so the one thing
that I would say that comes after free
speech is being open about your views
and passing judgment so you don't just
kind of say we can all have a discussion
every view is equal no not every view is
equal my view is much better than yours
yeah and here's why and here's why and
more importantly let me convince you
this is how these kind of things why
these things are useful this is how
society develops right it's not just
that some some people decide to write
this is the way we're going to go and
that sits without question it develops
through argument through struggles
sometimes it goes backwards sometimes it
leaps forwards but without this thing
that we've forgotten without free speech
and without free debate you just stand
still or you just sort of agree that any
of the and that's why we've got to the
position where feminism is a kind of its
like blaspheming if you speak out
against feminism this thing that wasn't
invented that wasn't an idea you know 40
years ago is now the unquestioned kind
of god-given sacrament that you cannot
you cannot even criticize to the kind of
most tiniest then that is bizarre you
know and that's when it becomes Dogma
firm ism has become dogmatic it's like
you know you cannot question it and the
people who are setting the tone of what
feminism means or so on present so
unrepresentative
of kind of the population of women in
this society I think that's just
terribly wrong one thing I always find
interesting is when people use the word
oppressed
I'm oppressed this culture of oppression
as somebody who has family in Venezuela
I'm not really you were pressed you know
is you know our Debenhams really
oppressing you by saying that you you
know you're a size fourteen or you know
it's a jumper really oppressing you
because I have to fit into a large now
do you know all these different things
and I just sometimes think that we take
these words and we twist them until the
original meaning of the word is actually
lost yeah definitely I mean it's very
hard to look at that anything like that
seriously oppression abuse we've got now
as especially in relation to the whole
discussion about sexual harassment this
new phrase came up sexual misconduct
what does that mean I mean what does
sexual misconduct mean it could mean
anything it literally could mean
anything
in the same way that now oppression can
mean anything and you've got you get the
example of Venezuela I mean you've got
people being lined up and
as an oppression that's kind of the kind
of worst kind of oppression when your
your life is being threatened if you
don't tow the line and then you've got
people talking about you know the
cultural appropriation discussion in the
West where Kim Kardashian wearing a
certain set of braids is oppressive to
whatever people who supposedly own
braids so how can you have a serious
discussion about this and you want to
have serious discussions about
oppression it's a real thing that
happens in the world still it's a real
thing that sometimes happens in this
country still too that's why I was gonna
bring up while we focus on these side
dishes as you said before actually this
was one issue we talked about before we
started the show there are serious
issues happening in this country and
this culture of fear and speaking out
political correctness not offending
people does mean you know I told you we
wanted to have Sarah champion on the
show who's an MP who spoke out about the
grooming gangs and rather AMA and others
and you know she said look I wouldn't
feel comfortable after probably after
what happened to her when she spoke out
and we have a very international is so
first of all you wrote about this so can
you tell our audience you might not know
anything about it and actually I became
quite aware that like when Americans
hear like about grooming gangs it's such
a weird way of talking about no one even
knows what it means so can you just lay
that out and kind of your thoughts about
how that's happened okay so what
happened it's an incredibly complicated
case so just to really sort of boil it
down essentially in certain parts of the
northern the UK there was sections of it
was in in Rochdale in Rotherham and in
some other parts of it was New York sure
there were groups of grooming gangs who
are essentially groups of men who groom
predominantly young women and get them
to through the abuse of drugs or through
threats to be essentially sex slaves for
them and they were prostituting out some
of these women but they were certainly
raping them on a mass scale and so we're
talking about thousands of
yes yes it was its kayak chily don't
think a number has been put on it
specifically because the cases are still
ongoing and they are unearthing new
cases now but this was allowed to happen
allowed to happen it seems because the
police were very nervous about
prosecuting or opening up a case about
some of these men because some of them
not all of them but a quite a large
proportion of them were British
Pakistani men and sarah champion was an
MP in one of the areas and what she came
out and said was she'd had some
complaints from some of her constituents
there were some women who went to social
services that was some of these girls
were very very young and there some of
them I think were even as young as 14
and they had made complaints to the
police they had made social services
Sarah champion was pushing to get an
investigation into what was going on and
I think what she said and certainly what
came out of it was that she was told
that because of a fear of a backlash of
racism against the Pakistani communities
in these areas that they weren't going
to investigate this and they were just
essentially going to ignore it and as a
consequence lots of predominantly white
working-class young girls were
systematically raped and abused there
have been some sort of there's been some
recognition of this in relation to there
was a kind of BBC drama about it there's
been some discussion about it in the
news however it was sort of this all
broke at the same time as me too
happened and I'm telling you the
contrast between the airtime that me too
got and their time that the rather much
tell scandals got was astonishing how
different it was this really wasn't
something that people wanted to talk
about and I mean you've got a national
discussion about rape and sexual
harassment and then you have a you know
huge example of the systematic rape of
very young girls and you can't put two
and two together and I don't really know
how to feel about it because I don't
think it's that people don't want don't
see this is wrong I don't think that
it's that people don't understand that
it doesn't matter what race or ethnicity
what kind of person you are that raping
someone is wrong but I think it's
interesting in a kind of very dark way
that essentially a fear of political
correctness or a fear of giving offense
and raishin to the racism the Pakistani
communities meant that there was a
weighing up of justice and that like you
said thousands of girls did not get the
justice do you think a large part of it
is fear of having your personal
reputation tarnished and being seen to
be racist or being tolerant of
Islamophobia essentially perpetuated
these young girls unfortunately being
sexually abused and raped I think that
definitely plays a part of it I mean as
a public official whether you're a
social worker or police officer or
someone in a position of authority who's
meant to have a responsibility to a
community you have to not be you have to
not be afraid to put your neck on the
line and and you have to not be afraid
to kind of go to the dark places that
maybe some cases might take you so there
was no reason why you couldn't at the
same time as say the reality is large
groups of Pakistani men are raping large
groups of white working-class girls and
say by the way that doesn't mean that
every Pakistani man in the UK is a
rapist who's not yeah why would you make
that why would that link be made and if
that link was made by certain racist
people in the UK you would argue against
that but but that takes guts because
that means you know that means saying
that you're going to make a very very
principled stand on something and they
didn't they chickened out of doing that
and as a consequence you had terrible
tragedies happen so they're kind of yes
the fear of PC can have very very dark
consequences and it means that people
can't you can't get to the truth so
sometimes the truth is what you don't
want to hear and in the fact in this
case it was something
you know clearly quite racially loaded
you can ask questions about why it was
that it was predominantly this group of
people that did this without at the same
time saying that you then mount a
nationwide racist campaign against the
Pakistani community I just I don't see
why they think that was not possible and
do you think also as well that then that
the authorities refusing to do with this
issue head-on as an fueled the rise of
the far right and people like Tommy
Robinson and who say well you know
you're not going to get justice through
traditional means the only way you're
going to get it is through supporting me
and I will help you it's a gift to them
to do this because what you're saying is
is yeah you were right the British
police are biased against their
protection of these groups they aren't
going to go to the truth so you have to
join us and we're going to get together
and get in the back of vans and go and
sort out these communities I mean why
would you want to embolden that point of
view what you want to say is as a
society we have generally liberal and
and good and decent attitudes to justice
and to the truth and we don't need
people like you going around and
capitalizing off this anytime you censor
any kind of difficult discussion like
this and anytime you say this is you
know too hot to handle too hot to talk
about especially relation to free speech
with someone like Tommy Robinson or you
can't criticise Islam or you can't and
talk about the Burke or you can't talk
about anything like this then what they
say is haha we told you you know this is
that what they're trying to do is
they're trying to hide it from you and
there's this fantastic
example as Alex Jones they're kind of
horrible actually find him funny he's so
mad there's been best black someone set
his rants to a Bon Iver song and it like
works perfectly because he's it's just
like talking about eating babies and
smelling himself like that stuff anyway
he's been banned off Twitter and if you
look at his website Infowars or anything
like that
all he's talking about is the fact that
he's been banned and this is why people
love him so what are you doing if you
want to actually beat him all you have
to do is say
for example his conspiracy theory that
the Sandy Hook massacre didn't happen
all you should have to do is say shall
we take a trip to the graves of the kids
that died and I like we can show you
that there you know that why they died
and we have the facts you were wrong by
banning those kind of ideas by saying
that they're too dangerous for people to
even see or read obviously the question
then is why what are they saying
is there some truth to it you know it's
just a total gift to the right I think
that's the thing with like it seems
often that you're the idea the
conversation is around free speech
they're academic to a lot of people
they're just these people sitting in a
room talking about it because they've
got nothing better to do well when it
comes to something like rather I'm and
writes down all these things you see the
practical consequences of not allowing
difficult conversations to happen in
public and they have an impact on you
know really a very significant terrible
terrible impact on thousands of young
people yeah not just those examples but
it has a real impact on how people
associate with each other so if you push
a culture in which people are afraid to
speak openly for fear of being told that
they're you know in breach of hate
speech laws or you know that they're
even on low-level stuff they kind of get
called a racist on Twitter which might
not necessarily affect them anywhere
outside of Twitter but isn't very
pleasant what you mean is you have a
society where people don't speak opening
to each other you know you can you can
make jokes about the fact that we are
now becoming a sort of bystander Society
you know when I find it fascinating then
when things happen people always filming
on their phones rather than getting
involved but all this stuff is having a
knock-on effect there's some changes
that you can kind of feel in relation to
how people relate to each other people
are much more cautious you know less
likely to talk to each other less likely
to say stop it that's like to say to
support each other and so then you don't
want to get to a position where people
are so afraid of each other that we
don't interact and we become a kind of
society of very individualized you know
and he's antisocial people that would be
a very very bad thing to happen and if
you clamp down on free speech that is
what's going to happen well speaking of
things that
get talked about our last question
always is what is the one thing that no
one's really talking about that we ought
to be talking about and when I say we I
don't mean just as I mean society in
general well it has been the thing that
I want to raise is has been talked about
and it hasn't and it's abortion rights
is something that's very very close to
my heart and it's something I care about
deeply and we just had in Ireland
fantastic win for women's liberation in
relation to the repealing of the Eighth
Amendment which was a very very archaic
law in the constitution piece of the
Constitution which said that women
weren't allowed to have abortions even
if they were about to die essentially
and that's been repealed Ireland is now
in the process a very lengthy and
terrible process of rewriting some new
laws but in the UK what people don't
know and lots of women who call
themselves feminists and you know
applying about women's action don't know
is that in the UK abortion is illegal
technically so under our laws it is
legal for women to have abortions if
they convince two doctors of their need
and that need has to be in terms of
either a threat to the mental health or
the physical health of the woman so you
gotta prove it's gonna turn you mad or
kill you if you if you have this baby
and the law is only the 1967 out it
really only works to protect doctors
from criminalization so we still have a
situation in which there's now abortion
pills which women are taking online
that's illegal
and these kind of things so people don't
know that they don't know that by law
women's bodies are not their own and you
know if you go to a doctor and you want
to get an abortion because most doctors
in this country are very good and
believe in you know women's health will
not necessarily say to you so proved to
me that you're going to be mentally ill
it's relatively easy but the fact is by
law it is still illegal and we can talk
about you know women's liberation we
talked about feminism from the point of
view that your body should be your own
bodily autonomy if we really really
believe that women we can trust women to
make decisions then we should change
that fact so I think that we should be
anyone who's at all interested in
women's liberation should be pushing for
the decriminalization of abortion and
that means that abortion will be
available as early as possible but as
late as necessary without condition you
don't ask her wherever or not it's
because she doesn't like the sex
wherever or not it's because you know
she's already got twenty twenty-five
nobody has twenty five children remember
Jory's has five children whatever the
reason it's her decision people get very
very upset when I talk about that
because they feel very strongly that
abortion is wrong it's not about whether
abortion is right or wrong it's about
whether or not women shall have control
over their bodies there's such a
difficult issue that abortion isn't
there because on the one hand I mean the
evidence is there actually allowing
women to access to abortion not just in
terms of their individual autonomy and
everything else but from a societal
point of view it massively cuts crime
because women generally know when
they're not really in a position to have
and bring up the childhood they they
could potentially do another hand I mean
here's a human life right at some point
right and it it's such a difficulty I
have no idea where I stand on it because
it's very difficult but you know when I
hear you say as late as necessary I'm a
bit like you're talking about nine
months you know it's a difficult
difficult issues well that is qualified
by the fact that the number of women who
get late abortions is tiny because it
involves a very very painful and
traumatic thing which I'm not going to
go into be you can imagine what that
involves involves giving birth to and to
something which is not know which is no
longer living the idea that women want a
cavalier about doing that is mad and so
that is not but the point is that will
only happen in cases when it needs to
happen and when it needs to happen is
when that woman needs it to happen that
is the that is the principle line in the
sand you have I mean I know you said
it's very and it's a very difficult
issue for me
just such a simple issue is that if you
value women as individuals and society
as free agents and society their
decisions their needs their rights come
above the rights of the fetus and it's
that's that's their bodies it's their
decision when that life exists outside
of them that is a different matter
that's why we don't allow women to not
that they do but we don't allow women to
murder children that's why that's
illegal when it's inside someone's body
it's a whole different discussion right
and thank you very much for coming in
and is there anything that you would
like to promote to applaud maybe your
Twitter handle your book and all the
rest of it so you can find me on Twitter
at sutter
I need to change it Ella underscore M on
school Whelan well we'll put it in the
video so people my book is called what
women want fun freedom and an end to
feminism and if you like pink it's pink
and if you like hearing some
alternatives to what's going on with
feminists and today give it a read
perfect thank you so much for coming on
great all right well listen guys if
you've enjoyed it this week as I'm sure
you have subscribers always to our
channel click that Bell button next to
subscribe button on YouTube so you get
notified when we release a video follow
us at trigger pod on Twitter on
Instagram on our Facebook page share the
clips that we put out every week and
there's always give us suggestions for
guests you'd like us to talk to thanks a
lot guys and hopefully see you next week
[Music]